all right you know i love to serve up i
can't get past my band's chest hair
it's awesome i'm sorry but you do know
also that i love to serve up the latest
and greatest on social media this is
what i'm liking
[Music]
just the gift that keeps on giving um
you might have caught this viral video a
couple weeks back when a mom surprised
her son with tickets to see his idol
diana ross it was on april fool's day so
at first he couldn't believe it
you want to go to diamond playing the
lost concerts here
okay you know
it's april fools i touched you
where is this texas
are you kidding me
you gotta drink you're shaking
i'm just going to say like 14 years old
that's pretty great taste if your idol
is down to ross i'm just saying um and
14 year old louie was very overwhelmed
and at that moment he could have no idea
just how huge his diana ross experience
would become we have louie and his mama
kayla on the line right now who watch on
nbc 10 wjar
what's up y'all
how are you i mean louie i just i just
have to say first of all amazing taste
in music i'm gonna leave with that
um so kayla it was the sweetest thing
ever and those tickets were for that
that next night in a different state
right yeah so louie's been a big fan of
diana ross ever since he learned about
motown music through the show motown
magic on netflix my youngest son watches
that show and he really fell in love
with diana ross and her music so he
showed me the tickets and he's like mom
diana ross will be in austin i'm like
louie buddy no we live in rhode island
that's austin texas across the country
no way so later that night i bought the
tickets obviously didn't tell him until
april 1st april april fool's day as you
just saw
and 10 minutes after that video we were
driving to the airport i had our bags
packed ready to go checked into our
flight on the way to the airport i
whipped up a tick tock and while we were
on the flight it went viral and we got
off and realized it went viral saw the
comments somebody in the comments
mentioned that it was a benefit concert
and
we decided to link that donation page to
my tick tock and here we are
yeah that's crazy so louie
it turns out that your mom's idea to
link the non-profit made a huge
difference so explain what happened
yeah so donations kept coming in like
crazy and we didn't even know that until
the acgc um
contacted us to join them in their vip
dinner
and
after the vip dinner they called us both
up on stage we were like what and that's
when they gave us the front row tickets
and the diamond room gave us our um
diamond gifts
and the concert as you see
he came out and i am and i almost passed
out
it was over it was insane
it was the greatest day of my life i
just love that this started from you
just watching something on difficult you
just loved telling your mom that your
mom is so rad and actually like went and
got the tickets and took you there
that's amazing you have an incredible
mom
kayla is amazing putting all of us moms
to shame flying across the country
that's amazing thank you guys so much
lily kayla this is such a great post i'm
liking it right now right
all right and that's not all our season
long partner pilot pin makers of g2 the
go-to pin of the kelly clarkson show
they want to honor ultimate
overachievers and that's like y'all so
they're gonna be writing you a check for
a thousand dollars how about that
thank you oh my god
thank you guys so much i'm so glad you
got to see her in concert lily
[Music]
you